[Musique]
le lieu semble encerclée par la forêt
et pourtant la syrie genest est installé
aux portes de la ville de luxeuil les
bains au coeur de ce qui fut aussi le
pays du meuble
c'était une affaire de famille mais elle
appartient aujourd'hui à une coopérative
ici on ne se contente pas de aussi les
grumes on s'emploie aussi à assécher le
bois mieux on le prépare pour faciliter
le travail des fabricants de meubles et
ça c'est plutôt étonnant
alors ses plans chemin vous avez toute
la gamme c'est un client qu'il va
fabriquer du meuble de collectivités là
pour le coup des lits des lits qui vont
être destinés aux internats des des
élèves
donc vous avez toute la gamme du produit
pour faire un livre il faut des fang li
sé les pièces de bois qui sont derrière
vous faut des tasseaux pour fixer le
sommier c'est le colis tic au dessus et
puis forcément pour dormir
confortablement il vous faut les lattes
de sommier c'est les pièces donc le
client sa spécialité c'est faire du
meuble je lui livre exactement ce dont
il a besoin dans la qualité donnée la
longueur précises dont il a besoin
bien sûr la syrie travaille avec de
grandes sociétés
mais elle n'oublie pas non plus les
artisans le bois est partout présent
nous on va livrer des clients qui vont
faire des chaises pour bébés jusqu'à
malheureusement du cercueil donc
tous les usages du bois sont représentés
[Musique]
des ébénistes qui conçoivent des meubles
il n'y en a pas beaucoup
mais grâce au web et en cherchant bien
on peut découvrir des créateurs
surprenant dans ce hameau isolé
hugo de la vesle un enfant de
haute-saône fabrique des meubles qui se
vendent parfois très longue
alors là c'est du mélèze donc qui vient
de chez un partenaire six heures de
franche comté du mélèze deux pays et on
a débité on va le travailler
prochainement sa destination d'un
chantier aux etats-unis et ce sera un
canapé sur une terrasse ici il n'ya pas
de magasin tout est vendu sur internet
cet ancien compagnon du devoir qui a
étudié le design en allemagne perpétuera
savoir faire en s'appuyant sur un
nouveau modèle économique sur la toile
ces tabourets de bar notamment
connaissent un vrai succès comme le
reste de sa gamme mois le meetic des
imprimés on est au début ni story
c'était vraiment la fabrication de
meubles en bois massif et je voulais
redévelopper ça
ce qui fait que j'essaie de me poser des
questions pourquoi est-ce que ça
disparaît c'est est-ce que c'était une
fatalité et je pense que moelleux
le gros du manque des artisans non ça a
été de se remettre en question et de
faire évoluer leurs pratiques
la proposition commerciale trop à
l'étroit dans cette ancienne ferme le
chef d'entreprise recherche maintenant
un local plus grand pour développer son
chiffre d'affaires d'autres créateurs de
meubles mise aussi sur le net pour
vendre leurs produits
c'est le cas de laurent vima le dernier
en france à fabriquer des tabourets
d'horloger
[Musique]